عدد طلاب الجامعات في افغانستان الى صفوف
الدراسه بعد مرور عطله الشتاء لكن
ارتيادها بالنسبه للنساء ما يزال محظورا
منذ عوده طالبان الى سده الحكم في اغسطس
قبل عامين وفرض الطالبان التي لم تتلقى اي
اعتراف رسمي بحكومتها الحضره بعد اتهام
الطالبان او الطالبات بتجاهل قواعد اللباس
الصارمه واشتراط ان يرافقن قريب ذكر والى
الحرم الجامعي قال المبعوث الخاص للاتحاد
الاوروبي الى افغانستان توماس نيكلسون انه
لم يسمع اي التزام واضح من وزراء طالبان
مؤكدا انهم لم يتعهدوا باعاده فتح المدارس
والجامعات للفتيات خلال العام الدراسي
الجديد ومن كابول ينضم الينا من هناك
مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر اهلا بك عبد
الله يعني
الذكور الرجال عادوا الى الجامعات في
افغانستان ولكن فعليا شكرا ولكن فعليا
الاناث لم يعودوا حتى الان ما وقع عوده
عوده الذكور الى الجامعات وهل هنالك من
ضغوط ربما
تمارس الان على طالبان شعبيه من الجمعيات
الحقيقيه النسائيه
نعم لقد توجه البنين والشباب الى الجامعات
صباح اليوم الى الجامعات الحكوميه
والاهليه دون الفتيات والبنات وهذه
العمليه التعليميه كان من المتوقع ان تحضر
او ان تتوجه كذلك الفتيات في هذه في هذا
هذا العام الجديد الى الجامعات والمدارس
ولكن لا يبدو او لا يظهر هناك اي شارده
لفتح الجامعات والمدارس فوق الصف السادس
الابتدائي امام الفتيات والبنات وطالبان
تبرر بانها بصدد وضع اليه ووضع يعني مناهج
تعليميه خاصه
للفتيات والبنات ولكن الامر وضع هذه
المناهج واليه التعليميه للفتيات والبنات
استغرقت اكثر من 18 الشهر ما يساوي 130
يوما وبالتالي الاوساط التعليميه
الافغانيه
غاضبون عن هذا
هذا ايقاف ايقاف الجامعات والمدارس امام
الفتيات الضغوط الضغوطات الخارجيه
والداخليه لم تؤثر على طالبان لحد الان
فقد كانت هناك يعني لقاءات ومناقشات
ومباحثات مع مسؤولي طالبان من جهه اطراف
دوليه بما فيها الامميه وكان اخر هذه
المناقشات والمباحثات لممثل الخاص للاتحاد
الاوروبي توماس نيكل الذي ظهر امس الاحد
في مؤتمر صحفي هنا
واشار الى انه التقى بمسؤول من طالبان
وناقشه مع هؤلاء
فتح اعاده اعاده فتح الابواب الجامعات
والمدارس امام الفتيات ولكن لم يسمع منهم
اي التزام حيال فتح هذه المدارس والجامعات
امام الفتيات وهذا يعني ان طالبان لحد
الان ليس لديها اي عمليه او اي اليه وخطه
لفتح الجامعات المدارس للفتيات